TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's
talk a little bit
about timeline cards.
Now these can be text, images,
they can be rich HTML, and
they can be video.
They can also be bundles
of items.
You'll notice the fold in
the upper right-hand
corner of this item.
Well that means it's a bundle.
And if the user taps on it,
they'll get a sub-timeline of
sorts of multiple items.
Now there's two ways that
this can happen.
One, if you inserted a single
timeline item with multiple
pages, or if you inserted
multiple items with a single
bundle ID that links
all of them
together in a single thread.
Now let's look at all
of that in code.
A simple timeline insert
looks like this.
I just add some text into a post
request on the timeline
collection.
If I were to do an image, it
will look like this-- again, a
post request in the timeline
collection.
But in this case, it's a
multi-part request with the
image data added.
I can also do HTML
and bundling.
Now this is the bundling for
paginated bundle, where it's a
single timeline item.
And you can see I'm specifying
the HTML and I'm also
specifying the HTML pages that
will show when the user taps
into the bundle.
If I wanted a threaded bundle,
it'll look like this.
It's a single timeline item
with a bundle ID.
Now I make the same bundle ID.
I add it to the payload of all
the other timeline items that
I want linked together in
this single bundle.
Now this is a RESTful web
service, so of course, we can
also do updates, deletes, and
we can get a list of all of
the timeline items we have
access to or more details
about any one particular
timeline item.